there we go okay
being the appointed hour i'll call the
work session on house bill
1417 to order
i have invited representative
ken weiler
to give us a little background
because we've had this discussion
repeatedly
and so just to give us a 30 000 foot
bring us up to speed i would appreciate
you
letting the people here and the public
fill in the blank spots
thank you mr chairman
representative ken weiler rockingham
district 13.
i've
been in kingston since 1970
and the retirement system was created in
68.
and first few years i lived in kingston
70 50 years ago
there were probably only four or five
people in the retirement system
maybe the chief of police fire chief
throat agent
town clerk
maybe
a librarian and of course all the
teachers
subsequently as i watched the growth
and i don't think my town was on typical
now the fire the fire department has
about 12 full-time employees
group two the police department has
about 12 group two the road department
always has about 10 full-time employees
so this is this is typical
of the growth of this retirement system
that we don't often refer to it's grown
so much since its inception
and
when i sat down to do the the budget for
um
12 and 13
i'm looking at this huge growth that i
had experienced to to date then
and
we couldn't even project it we were
working on a very tight budget
the democrats had overestimated the
revenue in the previous biennium and
then in this
first year of it they realized their
error and were trying to cut 200 million
out of it and one of the things they did
was reduce the
state's contribution to non-state
employees from 35 percent to 25 percent
i thought whoa we're going to see a lot
of pushback about this not a whimper
because the democrats did it
and
i wasn't empowered to do it then
so okay what are we gonna do
this looks like it's it's continuing to
grow i've got a budget so tight had to
cut it ten percent was the orders we all
followed
okay
if this
growth of this retirement systems keeps
going how can i predict how much to put
in this line for the 35 the 25 percent
at the time and uh
if if a town decides you know
everybody deserves a six percent pay
raise that's six percent more we have to
contribute if everybody decides we're
going to add 12 new employees that's 12
more employees we have to contribute to
those were things i could not control we
sat here in these divisions asking very
tough questions for all the people that
come before us to try to project where
are we going to be in 27 months
how much more are you going to spend how
much more increase do you see in this
this line on that line and we try to get
it very tight
because we have some very tight
sometimes
projections
so
what i did to change the 25 to zero was
caused all the employees to contribute
more
they added two percent to the group one
people who were contributing five
percent of the time mostly teachers and
then to the
uh police i think we added two and a
quarter and to the firemen two and three
quarters so everybody's contribution
went up i had a few people got in my
face this is a new tax you're screwing
me you're stealing my money i want it
back i said you will get it back when
you retire this is enforce pay and force
savings no one else can touch this money
this is your money i'm just forcing you
to put more of it in
up front
so
yes to seven percent but you were doing
the 20-year retirement you're up in 11
plus
but you've got a 20-year retirement so
and and you usually retire at higher pay
than the teachers or the group one
so this is going to help fund that
now about that same time we had to and
panel
a group because we were billions of
dollars underpaid because
in the in the 90s
the investments were doing fantastic
they were up around 10 percent
and we had assumed an eight and a half
percent
and so everything above eight and a half
percent they skimmed put in a special
fund i didn't think that was a good idea
having been in the stock market for a
while you know it goes up and it goes
down and it goes up and it goes down and
when it's up you've got to keep that
money for when it goes down to try to
level it up but we weren't doing that we
were skimming it we put it all in a
special fund and promise it would be
used
for cost of living adjustments well most
retirement systems except for the
federal government ones
if you want to have cost of living
adjustments you have to put in more
money if you only put in a certain
amount of money then when you retire
it's a fixed income forever if you live
another 30 years you don't go up a dime
in the in the private one so this is
somewhere in the in the middle uh
obviously we all see social security uh
increases at a small amount every year
not quite as much as inflation but there
is small increases so
that one money was used for a few years
in the 2000s for
um cost of living adjustments and the
teachers chose to have it be a
contribution to the retirement or to the
medical insurance which was getting very
expensive at the time so they choose to
take all their money instead of giving
it
and the other interesting thing was when
we took money and put it aside for a
cost of living adjustment for a
designated group
you knew exactly who was in that group
you knew how old they were what the
health history was and everything and
you were projecting out to end of life
for every member of that group and they
would say okay giving them two percent a
year increase or two percent a month
whatever uh increase in that budget
that means we've got to fund this much
money
but the assumption is
at eight and a half percent
we're assuming that we put two million
aside for you your group and and
and at the eight percent by the end of
your lives you'll all be set until we
run out of money okay
during that time we were also not
getting eight and a half percent on
anything
that whole decade
had an average of about five percent but
all these
these estimates kept going up and up and
up assuming eight and a half percent
assuming at half percent no we're making
five percent the delta kept growing so
by the end of that time we were billions
of dollars short and what the actuaries
said should be in that fund we had a
real problem
so in 2011 and 12
a group of our colleagues tried to get
together and try to say how are we going
to fix this one of the things they were
after was okay instead of a three-year
getting a three-year high we'll go to a
five-year high a lot of systems do a
five-year high the one i had from
american airlines went to a five-year
your best five years and uh
quite
a few other systems do five years rather
than three years
and then a lot of people
that were able to
were spiking it
the worst case was some
police chief
his last three years he took this the
assumption
okay if anybody's on overtime i'm on
overtime because i've got to be
responsible for them
so he had about an 80 80 or 90 hour
weeks work every week for pay
going into his retirement system for
that three years
which didn't stay in there long enough
to give any appreciation but when he
retired he retired at a higher pay than
what he was earning
because of the spiking that of course
was an
an extreme case and doesn't happen
everybody but
occasionally when the union leader
publishes who gets the most in the
retirement pace sometimes i remember one
year it was just a state trooper making
105 thousand a year
how did he manage that he wasn't wasn't
a
captain he wasn't a lieutenant he wasn't
a sergeant just a trooper
making 105 000 a year we had to have a
lot of overtime so
a few other people managed to spike it
as well so
those are the things we have to worry
about when we're trying to design how
much do we contribute and it's even
difficult
in the state budget for the eleven
thousand employees we have but most of
them being in group one it's very
difficult for them to spike because
they'll get comp time or something else
rather than they'll run a lot of them
are on salary so it doesn't affect us as
much but for police and fire and
corrections department
it is a common problem there's a lot of
people with a lot of overtime whether
they want it or not
and
so the idea was no more spiking and they
set something up that i thought at the
time said okay you're gonna your last
five years you can get no more
than what you got the average overtime
for all the rest of your career
so there's no sense trying to spike it
but state of the average you had now i'm
hearing that
somebody's interpretation whether it's
the union or the retirement system isn't
counting any of their overtime in the
last five years and that's wrong and i'm
opposed to that and i think we've got a
bill that takes care of it
but i think the bill we're talking about
that one's on monday that was on monday
all right but the bill we're talking
about i'm also opposed to it says oh
we're in property tax problems because
you took away our 35
that was back
decades ago or a decade ago so how come
all of a sudden it's a big deal
let's give a seven and a half percent
well that's kind of a foot in the door
hoping to get 35
and i already took care of that we're
already been now from since 2012
not contributing to non-state employees
retirement systems that's
that's been settled so to act like it
suddenly caused the um uh
state taxes to go up the state taxes or
the school taxes go up because the
schools 80 85 percent go into the
schools no one's controlling
the staff surge
typically okay we have 38 fewer students
this year we hired 18 people huh
i'm seeing that in some of my school
reports and that's not untypical so
i remember back in 1999 we were sued you
have to give more you have to help the
schools more you have to give them more
money for property tax relief okay
19.99 we gave 200 million more back to
the towns for property tax relief
forty percent of them had set
their school budgets so they couldn't
spend any more on schools but they gave
property tax relief for one year for
forty percent of the towns
the next year every cent we sent to them
went into
more money in the schools they were
hiring like crazy
and so gee that didn't work so well we
meant to reduce property taxes but i
guess it didn't work out
so everything that we tried since
claiming property tax relief always just
gets grabbed up and spent
and this pr
current bill
is 28 million dollars in the fiscal note
i didn't make the number up
28 million dollars
and at seven and a half percent
to
uh to the towns from to help with the
contributions the retirement system
okay
28 million dollars
to 1.3 million people and assuming
one-third are taxpayers because it's
about three people in each
house that pays taxes
you know
am i going to get excited about that for
property tax savings
my taxes will go up more than sixty
dollars and the schools will keep
increasing
so
i see it as wasted money
it's not going to do what we intended to
do
we figured out something by this
committee i give credit to karen
umberger the way to reduce property
taxes was to take it off of the swept
everybody has it in that tax bill
so much for the school tax so much for
the swept tax statewide education
property tax
that's been
for probably
20 years
336 million dollars and at one point
there was a lot of fight over donor
towns and we got rid of that
you remember that well being from a
donor town so it's a lot of big deal no
more donor towns so everybody gets the
swept and gets to keep it
and some of them might need it
some of the towns don't need it but they
get it anyway and uh so
if you reduce the swept
then that comes right off your property
tax bill i estimate maybe 250 dollars
per taxpayer
is getting saved
and another important thing we
frequently overlook
is the people that come and vote for us
the people that come and talk to us
about the taxes and so on they only
represent about 50 of those paying the
taxes
33 percent is paid by businesses
and another 18 percent is second
homeowners some of them may live in new
hampshire some may live out of state
they're all getting saved some money in
property taxes will reduce the property
taxes but
one of the one of the big selling points
is usually if we get only get more
people to pay income tax we can reduce
the property tax no because if only half
the people are paying income tax and
everybody's getting saved to property
tax
you're all going to pay more that's
been proven in new jersey and
connecticut in the last 30 years
so anyway a lot of these schemes that
i've been looking at for now 32 years
saying
well this is a way to save property
taxes no
it's a false
idea
it won't work so i'm opposed to this
bill i don't think we should start
contributing to
municipal
retirement systems again because it's
uncontrollable
and we all sit here trying to control a
budget
and say okay how much more are you going
to spend on that how much try to cut it
down
we can do nothing about municipal and
county's funding funding from this place
all we can do is sit and watch it and
just keep paying more
so
if we if we really do something like the
swept we can reduce property taxes but
any of these other schemes
the schools gobble it up so
that's that's my spiel on what i
remember from history of the retirement
system that was certainly the whole
waterfront
[Laughter]
i've been waiting to explain that for a
long time
well done any questions from the
committee
yes maury
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative very helpful background
you mentioned with regards to police
fire corrections over time whether they
want it or not
so my question is is there categories of
overtime mandatory versus voluntary and
is it accounted for
within those categories
i can't give you a definitive answer but
my belief is it is not
but you know so so okay do we count this
over time do we not count that over time
if it's compulsory do i get that added
to my retirement if it's not compulsory
you know
you know so
as far as i know i don't believe
when it goes in to the retirement system
or when it goes into your payroll it
says whether this was mandatory or
or whether it was voluntary
so i i couldn't answer that exactly
representative alicia
thanks mr chairman uh good to see you
representative
peter you and i were both on finance so
we started cutting uh
35 to 25 and ultimately to zero
and i specifically remembered as i
chaired division one at the time
that we all said at the time though we
can't make any promises that we would
try to restore some of that money at
some point to those communities maybe
not 35 or 7.5
as this bill is calling for but
something but did i hear you correctly
you don't think we should make any
contribution
to the municipalities for retirement i
do not because it's too unpredictable
when we're trying to do 27 months out in
the future what's going to happen
in the budget that we put together and
we can't feel confident that we won't
see things like some of the previous
decades all sorts of hiring and pay
increases and i know this pay increase
is coming in the future because of
inflation will drive them
you can't get anybody to work unless you
go way up in pay so if you've got to
fill the job you're going to make pay
more and then you're going to have to
put more in the retirement system i see
a flood of that coming and
we just passed a budget that's going to
be affected in the next year and it's
still going to be the same budget and if
we said and we'll have to start
increasing pay in the in the in the
state employees
the only saving grace there will be
because there's so many vacancies that
there'll be extra money in the payroll
fund
to make up for the probably the likely
pay raises that we'll be asked to
approve so
that that may come out okay
i have nothing further mr chairman
thank you mr chair thank you ken our
representative weiler for your
rendition
um just just a couple things one thing i
i do understand the exponential growth
in employees and communities and around
the like but i also understand that in
1967 the population in new hampshire was
under 500 000.
now it's 1.3 million so
this growth we're talking about there's
a correlation between population and the
demands on municipalities state
government and everybody else to serve
that population so
i'm not concerned about that
but what i am concerned about is i also
was here when we promised
the municipalities when that was taken
away that we would do what we can to
restore this
and here's and and i hate to be labor
appoint but i'm very serious when i say
this
we're sitting at a time now and who
knows how long that's going to last
where we have a
robust monies within the state coffers
we have still today may change soon
uh robust income to the state government
and we just sat in this division and i'm
sorry to say this
and there was a vote to send five
million dollars
to individuals
who were
shamed by a ponzi scheme
and my understanding is a ponzi scheme
only are successful
because of the
desire or greed of the people they scam
so i'm sorry i can't reconcile given
five million dollars to that
and reneging
on a promise we made to communities
and the people that serve those
communities and they all do serve those
communities
um that we made some years ago
based on an unknown factor and that's
what i understand you to stay in
anything we do here
all those unknowns always exist
and all we do is the best we can
to
have what we decide to do come in line
with those unknowns and not get
destroyed by them just like you
mentioned
many many times
the overestimates of revenues and we go
back to 2008 but what never gets
mentioned
and this can happen again and it will
happen again sometimes as the entire
economy collapsed
and that's what we were dealing with and
that's when we
through necessity
had to borrow money bake bone steel cut
where we really didn't want to to make
payroll
so
and when i i did that as a company
wouldn't say if i had to make cuts
um
i had to make promises or i had to make
commitments
and i had to keep those commitments or i
was done so
i'm sorry i do not agree that we should
not
fulfill
and that's what i'm talking about only
the obligation that we made
to communities and the people that serve
them
10 years ago
i think or 12 years ago whatever it was
i think we should fulfill that thank you
and thank you for your talents mr chief
i in answer to those two situations the
5 million
was
similar to the 100 million we're now
looking at for people who are abused by
government employees in the in the
sununu youth development center it also
happened
by the by the attorney general and the
bank and commissioner also lied to
people put out false reports and
investors relied on that information so
we're paying off for their mistakes from
back 10 12 years ago
but they deliberately lied
none of those people are in those
positions anymore and have been for
years
we are giving money back to the towns
they can use it for property tax relief
i've heard as high as 300 million some
of it through arp funds some of it the
100 million that we all know about
through the swept we're all giving we're
giving more money back but here's the
big difference if we decide to give
money back to help the towns
we give it back in a way we know the
exact amount this is the big difference
this is the big difference we know we're
giving you 300 million back for this
biennium here it is
do what you will but if we say okay we
agreed to pay a portion of this
we don't know what the portion is
that makes it very difficult when you're
doing a budget when i do a budget i have
to know where the money's going i have
to know how it will result and i have
auditors to go out and tell me what the
results were and if it didn't go the way
i think it is we'll change it but
i have to know how that money will go up
if i give you an exact amount i know
where that money's going but if i give
you a promise to pay a certain amount on
something something i have no clue
what that certain amount will be so you
see from a budgeting standpoint which
we're all working on very hard for all
our time and all our devotion here in
this committee is we got to know exactly
what what we're giving away and i don't
know it when i promise
a percentage
that's the thing that that i can't do
and still try to make a budget that
makes sense so
that's why i oppose giving a percentage
of something we are giving a percentage
of the meals and rooms tax we are
promising that
but
we can't we won't give it out unless we
get it
so
that's that's kind of related so that
makes it easy
represent griffin
as i read this bill the fiscal impact is
in uh
fiscal year 2024
and none of us know what the revenue
stream will be then that's true we're in
a high five
inflationary period now
there's a war going on in europe
and we could be facing a recession in a
in a flash
and i'm reluctant
to commit the next legislature
to spending and that's what we would be
doing i agree if we if we uh completed
this bill i agree
any other questions for representative
wilder
thank you very much thank you for your
patience
representative o'brien would you like to
make any comments
good afternoon i'm representative
michael o'brien i currently serve on the
house edna committee
for clarity in my credentials
i also am a vice president of board of
aldermen for the city of nashua
i'm also
was a firefighter for 35 years and
currently receiving a pension from new
hampshire retirement system so i think
between where in the hat
within the state and the municipality
and the helmet on the fire department i
have more than a fairly well
knowledge of the new hampshire
in
representative just as a i think i don't
think your mic is on
i'm sorry that's much better thank you
so much uh i'm sure they heard me
because i got the profound irish voice
so
i'll have you know i'm passing out the
papers the family did kiss the blondie
stone before they left and i did too but
anyways
this is truly if you look at it
a property tax bill
now if you look at one of the sheets
this was prevent presented by
the
new hampshire municipal association the
other letter is a cover letter for the
city of nashua now i can speak about the
city of nashville if you look at nashua
particularly in the figures compiled
that i have to agree with being on the
budget committee for the city of nashua
i did ask our cfo
to look at it that is over north of two
million dollars
in the city of nashua two million
dollars equals one percent of the tax
rate
so by this 35 percent lack of payment
costs the taxpayers
of nashville one million dollars
so
this could go to relieving the property
tax
now
it says there was a lot of problems this
is not anything to do with spiking
but you know if you want to talk about
spiking
geez
we changed the whole system for one
person in dover a police chief
and really kind of screwed the pooch on
other different things
statewide because i was of the opinion
if anybody works any type of overtime
the state of new hampshire new hampshire
retirement system makes a deduction out
of that paycheck goes into the fund and
what i know about banks and funds and
investitures
that money will double
and receive a profit by eliminating the
overtime that went into
the new hampshire retirement system
greatly in my opinion hurt the system
perhaps mr collin could explain money's
lost
by removing that now you say
representative moani and moony you
brought up
the point of uh overtime and do they
have a chance or opportunity
i think that goes by each individual uh
municipality and go by each contract
that the municipality works under
but basically i can give an example in
nashua
where
you signed a list to work overtime
and
it's a it's a voluntary list for you to
sign on but you cannot refuse it once
you get it
if you cannot work and you must seek
somebody of
you know of equal caliber to work that
particular overtime
that particularly holds true on
christmas eve and christmas day and
holidays and everything else
and the reason we have that is because
we value the life safety and i'm sure
other communities do
that's what overtime does we're talking
policemen and firemen
the state of new hampshire back door
told municipalities how to run their own
public safety
took away that opportunity
that's that's a great fault in my
opinion right there
we'll hire firefighters back because we
know
the type of force that is needed to
fight a particular fire firemen get hurt
they go to fires and they put themselves
at risk sometimes they make the supreme
sacrifice
so when somebody gets injured and now
with a you know broken leg or a broken
knob or whatever is
their issue we need to backfill and
that's where the overtime comes from
also there's vacation and sicknesses we
just went through covet we had
firefighters
you know you can't choose being a
firefighter on a medical run not to
treat a covet patient it was the same
thing in my active career we had the
same issues with somebody that was hiv
positive we never refused anybody
but sometimes you do get sick of
different things and exposures
and so you need the back coverage and
that's where the overtime came in and
like i say every dollar that i made in
you know there was better ways to
control the spiking
and that wasn't done
now
again i have to say
looking
um
looking what the individual
new hampshire retirement system
you've got to look at
part of the deal that's not really
addressed in this bill but
representative weiler mentioned
employees contributions kicked up
firefighters and police were paying
nine and three-quarters percent
into the pension system
now
police officers pay 11.5 and
firefighters pay 11.8 i don't know what
the difference of 0.3 percent is
between policemen and firemen when
traditionally firefighters end up
spending longer careers
in you know working for their
municipalities
but when you take that's basically two
percent
lack of earning power of the employee
when you take that chunk of two percent
where do you think the employees go to
make up that two percent they come back
to the municipality and they say to the
municipality i'm not making as much
money as i used to because it was taken
up within the increase in the pension
system so you inflated
the wages
of the employees
and i think that also hurt too
but
i when you ever figure a pension system
representative weiler there has been
talk in the past
of oh
in the example nashville you pay too
much
well isn't it the lara percentages
and basically if you make
let's say five dollars an hour and
somebody else makes ten dollars an hour
you put it you know take two percent out
the person that's making
you know two percent on ten dollars is
putting more money away it's equal in
the lower percentages the employees are
covering their particular costs at like
i say eleven point eight or eleven four
point five percent so it should equal
and out so there is a big thing the big
gap that occurs right now is looking at
the numbers and look at the
amount of cities and towns
and i think somebody from the new
hampshire municipal association can
explain it better but you can see the
how this really is a property tax bill
that affects the towns now my
recommendation would be
pay back to 35 percent you committed to
it
in 1967 and in 2012
it supposed to sunset and go back to the
or at least implied
and it didn't
so
believe me this is bargain basin
basement pricing
coming up to help out your cities and
towns to go into seven and a half
percent it will go a long way to really
support so i hope
i answered some of your questions and i
think we have other people that probably
back up you know more than what i say
here so not to waste your time but thank
you
would you entertain questions oh
absolutely anyone have any questions for
representative o'brien representative
thanks mr chairman uh nice to see you
representative o'brien and to you sir
do you know where the seven and a half
percent number came from
no and i'm quite if i may say so if you
look at the author of the spell the lead
representative was representative
cushing god bless us so
and uh what a wonderful gentleman and
i'm sure we all agree
and uh and uh you know terrible and his
uh untimely passing
uh
but uh he's the one that authored this i
did offer one previously at five percent
it did not make it past the house if you
remember uh last year that would have
been a better bargain basement deal for
you
but uh
i have to strongly agree and i agree
with this seven and a half percent so it
came from the original offer
but
in the city of nashua if you look at the
numbers it is really coming out to one
percent
so if that is reflective it probably
you'll see that more along trending
maybe with the other municipalities as
well
thanks thanks mr chairman
any other questions
thank you thank you sir
anyone else like to
make comments to the work group
good afternoon chairman emmerich my name
is catherine heck and committee members
i represent the new hampshire municipal
association and i did just want to say
that we did put together an anecdotal
survey with 62 political subdivisions
submitting what this bill
and the impact would be directly on
their budgets
and excuse could you
spell your last name i didn't get it yes
sir heck like what the heck h-e-c-k
okay i want to make sure was that okay
thank you very much you're welcome i get
asked that a lot
um so i did just want to um reiterate
that this is anecdotal some did the
exact calculation down to the penny
others did a little bit of rounding but
it was to show that there's overwhelming
support from the municipalities and our
association that's this would in fact be
greatly beneficial to our new hampshire
municipalities school districts there's
a county represented here as well as a
fire village district so i can certainly
take any questions
anybody have any questions for mrs heck
yes i believe one was handed to you if
is it this one yes sir
okay
you're welcome
thank you very much for your time thank
you
sing then we'll come back to the
division one committee
yes
thank you mr chair
um
i know that the policy committee when
they
when they looked at this bill
recommended
itl on the bill
and i know when it went into the on the
floor of the house
on the initial vote
itl passed
and later in the day when numbers were
dwindling in the house
there was a reconsideration motion made
and the bill passed by a tiny margin
but i keep coming back to the fact that
uh
we have no control over the hiring
of uh municipal employees
uh so it's a
it's really a moving target
but more importantly
the fiscal impact of this is in
and we as a current legislature i don't
believe should be committing
a future legislature
and
all that having been said i'd like to
make a motion if it's an order certainly
i'd like to move that we itl this bill
okay motions have been made for itl do
second thank you mr mooney okay
okay um
mr chairman before i i vote and call the
role i'd like to just to say that
out of respect for the division one
committee i will vote to itl however
in front of the entire finance committee
and on the floor of the house i will
vote to
not to itl but make a motion to ought to
pass
that being said uh i will call the role
with your permission
okay
um okay chairman aaron yes
uh
vice chairman griffin yes
the clerk votes
yes with reservations
yes
representative leishman no
remember them hatch no
and represent walls is absent so the
vote is four to two in favor of the ito
okay we will forward this to the full
committee for a executive session i
believe it is on the 23rd
with that the hearing for the work
session for
you